はい ではよろしくお願いします
今日はダンマパダの勉強ですね
何番 何番目ですか？今日は
70 70  これは昨日やりましたけどね
マセマセクサンゲーナ・バローブンジェータ・ボージャナーン・ナソーサンカタ・ダマーナーン・カランナアガティ・ソールシンという短い偈ですね
なんか分かりにくい すごい長いストーリーがありまして
結構長いな これ早く読む方法ないんですかね
注釈書のパーリ語っていうのはなかなか早く読めないんですね
ものすごい文法がややこしいんです
では 偈文の意味 マーセマーセクサンゲーナっていうのは
マーセっていうのは月のことですね
毎月毎月ですね で 月々だけご飯食べる
そういう どういう風に月一回ご飯食べるかというと
このクサンゲーナ あの
草っていうのは この草
日本語でも草ですね 驚いちゃった
で 草っていうのは まああの
ある特別な草なんですね
葉っぱは長い だから切って束にすることはできます
葉っぱ短い この芝にある草ではないんです
まあ葦でもないんですけど
まあなんかわからないね
何か日本語でもそういう特別な名前があると思いますけどね
要は葉っぱがちょっと長い草ですよ
で まあ牛が食べる草の中で
結構牛がまあおいしく食べる腰光ようなものなんです
そういう草の葉っぱをご飯の中に入れて
その葉っぱについているものは舐めて食べると
食べ方はそういう食べ方
ということは 決して体に十分は食べられないんですよ
それまた月一回ですからね
ということは この苦行のことを言ってます
行 バローブンジェータ・ボージャナ
バローっていうのは愚か者ということね
愚か者は苦行するんだと思って
修行するんだと思って
こんなことをやっていたってもね
事実上は不可能というかね
死んじゃ 死んじゃいますからね
ほとんど何も食べてない状態だからね
そういう風にご飯食べるよ
食べるという行をやっても 16
分の1にもならないんだと
価値は これサンカータダマーナーンというのは
サンカータダマーナーンっていうのは
この体で真理を体験するっていうことです
いわゆる悟ることなんですね
頭で理解することも足らないんですよ
頭だけで この知識だけで何かブッダの教えを理解したっても
心には入らないんですね
水分差があるんですよ
ですから この心で体験する
心で理解する 心底ブッダの教えを理解すること
ブッダの教えと言ったっても
無常のことを一切は無常であると
瞬間たりとも止まることなく変わっていくものであると
いわゆる物事 たとえ話で言えば
一切は滝のようなものであると
一切現象は 自分も他人も生命も物質も何でもかんでも
滝のように流れるものであって
止まるものではありませんと
で  そういうことが自分も無常ですから
これは経験できるんですよ
瞬間も自分というものが成り立たないんですね
ずっと変わって変わっていくんです
それをまあ体で心の深足を経験して理解していくことはサンカータダンマというんですね
あんまりこのよく使う単語じゃないんですね
だから無常を経験すること
まあ最低ブッダが言うのはヨルカというところにでも達していること
最高は阿羅漢果に達していること
どちらでもサンカータダンマ
もうダンマを真理をもう経験している
まあおそらくサンカータというのはこのサッチカローティという単語のが別な使い方やと思いますけど
あまり文学言語学的には分析はないんです
ですから辞書で決まってる意味でやってます
そこら辺はあまり皆様には関係ないんですから
一般的な意味で言えば
月一回だけ草の葉っぱでご飯食べていたってもどうったことはないんだと
16分の1の価値もないんだと
この16分の1では結構価値があるんではないかと皆様理屈で考えるかもしれません
だけど これは表現なんですよ
それは表現で 16分の1っていうのはね
で ちょこっと価値ある場合は 4分の1にするんです
微妙にまあまあというくらいだったら
16分の1ということはもう全然ほとんどもう価値がないって意味なんですよ
だからヨルカになることの 16分の1では相当の価値ですけど
そういうものでもないんです
ちゃんとした 16分の1っていう意味じゃないんです
まあ似ている表現 日本語でもあるでしょうね
ありますかね 佐藤さん
例えば 1文もないと言うでしょ
お金の場合はね そんなような
スズメの涙  そうそう まあスズメの涙とかね
まあ全然もう価値にならない
まあスズメの涙とか言ったっても
なんかちょこっとあるという意味になるんですね
まあ確実にそういう表現あると思いますよ
二束三文 二束三文  二束三文
二束で三文ぐらいの安い価値がないと
そんなものは価値がないもの
そんなものは二束三文だ
価値がないという意味だったら
それでいいかもしれませんね
で もう何の価値もありませんと
で そこで大胆にこの苦行の世界で
でもこの極限的な苦行のことを語ってます
この俗世間で我々の目に耳に入るような苦行じゃないんで
こちらで言っているのは
もう人間には実行不可能ですからね
月一回だけご飯食べる
それでもご飯食べてないんだからね
舐めるだけだから あの草の葉っぱっていうのは何もつけないでしょうね
あれは 水につけたっても濡れるわけじゃないし
あれが舐めて 舐められません
草の草という種類の葉っぱっていうのは
あれかなりケバケバというかね
感触はいいわけじゃないんです
だからそういうことですから
それぐらいの苦行をしたっても
まあ二束三文やと 森林を知ることで
そこで仏教 お釈迦様が語っているこの悟りの境地っていうのは
お釈迦様時代ではもう預流果になるっていうことはもうものすごいたくさん
もうほとんど説法一つ聞いただけでも預流果になったということがありましたしね
一旦預流果になった人は
それから確実に完全な悟りに達しますし
それほど難しいことではないし
何の苦行も要りませんし
ただ在家の人が何かもう何か困ったことがあって
お釈迦様に会って その自分の問題を言ったところ
お釈迦様は説法するでしょうに
それでほとんど説法を聞いたら
その人は悟りに達しますからね
預流果に だから修行はしてないでしょうに
修行も苦行も何とも してないんです
だからこの仏教の悟りっていうのは行ではないんですよ
智慧の開発だから 行はないんだけど
道徳はあります 道徳と行は違います
行っていうのは何かやることなんです
だから道徳と行の差がね
覚えた方がいいんですよ
例えば毎日朝 10万回題目を唱えますよと
午後も 10万回唱えますよと
いうと相当な難しいでしょう
題目と言ったっても 南無妙法蓮華経だから
あれもう 20回となるともう眠くなっちゃいますからね
いるんだからね 日本にそういう人は
それでも 10万回となると
選挙か何か時代ってくると
ここら辺どうか分かりませんが
あちこちで朝聞こえますよ
いろんな家で太鼓を叩きながら題目を唱えるのは
だからそれもかなりの苦しい行なんですよ
じゃあだからその人は性格的に立派な人間になるのかと
ならないんですよ 例えばもう酒でもね
日升瓶ぐらい置いておいて飲みながらもあれできますよ
どんな悪いことをしながらでもできないわけじゃないんです
題目を唱えて もうそれでも何か腹が立ったところで行って人を殴ったり殺したりすることも可能なんです
だから行と道徳は一緒にならないんです
ただ 山伏行やるとしたってもね
それは体力の勝負で 朝早く起きることとね
もう山をものすごい早足で登ることであって
当然体力 忍耐というのは必要ですけど
だからといって怒らない人間になる
生命に親切な優しい人間になるという事はどう成り立つのかと
しかし ああいう題目唱えることもなく
山を登ることもなく 滝行やることもなく
生命に優しく優しい人間になろうではないかということはできるでしょうに
だから生命に優しい人間になるんだと怒りませんよと
みんなそれぞれ平等じゃないんだから
一応みんな違いますからね
生命一つ一つ 気に入る生命も気に入らないものも
嫌なことやる人も もういろんな人間いるんですけど
みんなに優しくしますよと
そういうことは簡単にできますね
それは人格的な問題で
人格を変えることで で
自分が理性的で もう誰しない人間にはなりたくはないと思ったら
もう酒をその人はやめちゃうんですね
溺れるものは 依存するものはやめておく
何かに依存しちゃうと
人間はもう堕落するんですね
だから自分が人間としては堕落したくないというと
依存するものならもうやめる
酒 麻薬っていうのは依存するんだから
もうやめるんですね それから頭が悪くなる
まだ他のものも人間依存するものありますよ
ゲームとかね 賭け事とかね
一旦やりだしちゃうと
もうやめられないという精神的な病気が出てきます
それは精神的な病気なんですね
その場合も堕落しますね
確実に ですから 人には人格者にはそういうあまり罪にならない
ちょこっと行ってパチンコやったっても
そんなに罪にはなりませんだけど
依存する恐れもありますよと
ですから ものすごくそういう世界に気をつける
自分が依存する傾向だったら
きれいさっぱりやめる
いつでも依存は何にも依存しない理性がある人間だったら
適当にその都度その都度
もう人間関係で友達関係でゲームとかやったりもしますけど
依存はしないと そういうことで
このそういうのは人格的なことで
それは特別な行がなくてもできるんですよ
[背景音楽]だから行と道徳は一緒にはならないんです
また 行者はいろんな行者たちがいるんだから
ボロ服を着るとかね 日本のお坊さん見たってもいろいろいますよ
ものすごい豪華な服を着るお坊さんもいて
すっごくもう麻でできている
なんかものすごい質素な
感触もあまりよくない
あの 装束を着ている人もいるし
しかし そういう形は誰にでも取れますよ
それが行に入っちゃうんですね
問題は人格なんですね
人格的に立派な人間になるという場合は
別に服装は別に関係なくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことで この まず行と道徳っていうのは同じものでないということはよく覚えておかないと
行はずっとやれる やることはできます
しかし 心が変わるかないかということはなかなか言いにくいんです
ほとんどの場合は 論理的に言えば行にしがみついちゃうと心が変わらないんですよ
行が優先になっちゃうんですよ
だから宗教的な世界である
このあらゆる仕来り あらゆる儀式
宗教 どんな宗教でもあります
どんどんどうなってくるってことは
儀式が優先になってしまうんですね
人々は必死になって儀式を行う
そこで儀式がややこしくなってくると
怒るは怒鳴るは 何ヶ月間も苦労しながら計画立てるは
もうそれで必死になるは苦しむは
いろんなことはありますよ
仏教のいろんな念なんとか行
いっぱいあるんでしょうね
かなり疲れるんですよ
そこでちょこっとでも間違ったら
ものすごくそれに怒るは
で ある浄土真宗のお寺に行って
そちらの念 一般的な法事なんとかでしょうね
私に来てくださいって
説法してくださいと その
みんな集めてもらって
集めてやりましたけど
ある年上の男性二人ぐらいいて
ものすごく反発するんですね
お坊さんにも怒鳴っても 「
なんということは このお寺は日蓮なんだらかんだらの
日蓮じゃなくて何だ 親鸞なんだらかんだらのお寺ではないか」と 「
こちらは念仏を唱えるところだよ」と 「
この家では念仏を唱えるんだよ」と 「
なんで説法するんでしょうか」と
だからそちらが何も頭は使わず
ただ来て座るときは座って
立つときは立って 手を上げるときは手を挙げて
なめるときはなめてとかね
それで帰ると で  ちょこっと頭に入ること
心に入ることはダメということ
はっきりそのじじい二人がもうはっきりしているんですね
心にはアクセスするなよと
我々の生き方なんかはもう教えてくれるなよと
ただ行やりたいだけと
それで見栄を張るでしょうね
自分たちももうちゃんとやってますよと
それにしては今の若者は全然興味ないんだぞとかね
だからまあ 行にしがみつくと
そういう性格がすごく悪くなるんですよ
だからすごいもうだらしない
恥ずかしい態度を取ったんです
どうしても恥を見る羽目になりますね
もう戦い相手にしたのは私のことだから
もう勝てるわけないでしょうに
で  そこで それに私はいろいろ答え出して出していくところで
何のことなくよそ者になってしまっちゃうんですね
もう雰囲気を壊す人になっちゃって
もういい加減な屁理屈ばっかりするものではないかとかね
はっきり言えば 仏教って誰のもの
教えでしょうかと 私言ってますかと
人が犬を飼ったんだからって
犬のためにある家じゃないでしょうに
家の主人が犬を「じゃああんたあちらに行きなさいよ」と言ったら 「
何ということでしょうか」と 「
この家に住んでいる犬ではないか」と 「
そこは犬がいるところで放っておきなさい」というような話なんです
だから家の主人が出て行かなくちゃいけないんです
だから まあたとえ診断が正しくたっても
もう最近生まれた人でしょうに
そんな知識人でもないでしょうに
人類驚くほど何か何か作って書いて本とかありますかね
それでもないでしょうに
ただの仏教という世界で
一つの宗派が作っただけの話でしょうに
それも本人の開発じゃないでしょうに
念仏っていうのは大乗で昔からも普通にあったものでしょうに
昔 ちゃんとしたシステムの中で見事に合わせてあった念仏を特別にまるっきり合わせないように一新宗教にしただけで
だからもうそれだけでももうよそ者になっているでしょうし
だから なんで本物の大本のブッダの話はもう言うなよと
どういう理屈でしょうかと
そういう反論もありましたし
だから結局はまあ恥をすることになっちゃう
性格悪いということになっちゃうし
だからこの行に 仕来りに
儀式に固めたら必ず性格は直らないということにもなるんですよ
で なんで人間行が好きかというと
痛くなくできますよ 自分はそのまま放っておいて手足でできますからね
自分を直す必要ないんだから
自分を直すということはかなり痛いプロセスでしょうに
そっちを怒る人は怒らないようにするっていうことは
本人にしたら結構痛い道ですよ
自分を直すっていうことはね
そんな楽じゃないんです
だからそれは苦しいことはやりたくないと
自分のことそのまま放っておきなさいと
放っておいて 年表というか
もうカレンダーでどんな日でどんなお祭りやるのかと
それを教えてください
それを自分のスケジュール帳に書いておいて
この日はお寺に行く日だと
それが楽ですよ それからもうやりたい放題のことをやると
だから行と道徳は一緒にならないんです
しかし 理性がある人には行が性格を変えるために使うことはできます
それは行に理性が入っているならばなんです
理性が入らなくないともう迷信になっちゃうと
形而学的なことになってくると
もう何の意味もないんです
[背景音楽]どうも正挙っていうものはもう行ばっかしで始めるんですね
先生 行っていうのは 例えば朝一時間座禅するとか
そういうのを全部ですね
題目とか眠るっていうのは分かりやすいんですけど
ん？ そういうことも全部含めて行です
うーん だから朝毎日一時間座禅すると言っても
それは座禅しているんだからね
行にはなりませんでしょうに
なんで座禅するのかと
それは心を育てるためでしょうに
だからそちらには理性が入ってますよ
毎日この時間だよと決めちゃうと
まあ仕切りになりますよ
だから行の形を取ってます
毎日時半だと 時だと そこは行になりますよ
行になるんだから やめることはできなくなりますね
その時間になってくると
別な仕事はもうできなくなっちゃうんです
癖になってますから しかし
何やるのかというと もう座禅すんでこんでいるとかですから
そこで心を育てますからね
まあ論理的に言えば まあずっと座禅して瞑想して心を清らかにするのは一発で
まあそれは論理的であるし
あるいは一番もう効き目のある
心に効き目のある時間
時間を選んで選んで その都度その都度座禅に入るのはいいんです
それを出家している人以外は
これまた難しいでしょうし
だからこの理性に基づいて
行は人格向上には使えるということは言ったのはそういうわけなんです
行だけは関係 もう何も道徳には影響はないんです
それで 例えば自分が怠け者であると
三日坊主であると これ何とかしなくちゃと
それで三日坊主をやめるために毎日決めて何かやると
怠け者だから これまたすぐ朝早くやると
夏であろうか冬であろうか関係ないというと
本当は行をやってるのは行なんですけど
行によって自分が自分の怠け癖
三日坊主ですぐ何でも諦めること
それを叩いておくんです
それで道徳世界に入っちゃうんですね
だから行であっても 理性が入り込んで自分を直すために使うならば
その分はなんとか自分が直していけます
そういうことになってくると
行を選ばなくちゃいけない
どんな行ででも人格向上するわけじゃないんです
例えば 毎日万回題目を唱えると
題目には何の意味もないんですね
だったら毎日朝万回生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにと唱と
それは意味のある理性的な真理の言葉なんですね
生命は生命に親切にしなくちゃいけないっていうのは当たり前の話なんです
それで確実に自我が消えて悟りに達する
だから行によってもう修行成功したことになります
人格を完成したことになります
だから毎日万回唱えたいんだけど
何を唱えるかと選ばなくちゃいけないんです
天にまします神様は感謝いたしましてことを
もう万回ではなくて 百万一億回言ったっても何の意味もありません
そんなものはいませんだから
ですから この 行は自分の人格を向上するために使用するならば
行を選ばなくちゃいけない
何の意味もない行はいっぱい
たくさんあります だから道徳っていうのは毎日守ることでもあるし
なんとなく微妙に行と切り離せないというとこは当然あります
大体起きあがることやらお勤めやら
もう行になっちゃいますからね
だから行になってしまう
しかしそれで理性的な行
あるいは人格を向上するために直接影響がある行のみを選ばなくてはいけないんです
だから仏教の中でも当然五行に反対ですけど
いろいろ行は入ってます
そこでいろいろと言ったっても
無数の行の中で一部だけ選んで入れてやります
昨日の昨日でしたっけ
では 13種類のこれ行なんですよ
当時の社会環境を見て語られた行で
今はもうやっぱりその行もやっぱりできないんですね
瞑想するの場合 場合でも
やっぱり墓場に行って瞑想するっていうこともありまして
今はできないでしょうね
まあ墓場っていうのは
まあ俗世間の欲と見栄とかね
じりじりと現れる もうそれよりはパチンコ屋に行った方がいいという
墓場にいると もう行くともう宗教世界じゃないので
見栄の世界で 何の聖なる境地と処置
土地じゃないんです 昔は墓場の人間がそう悲しくて
死んだ人はそこで置いといて帰る
もう行きたくはない また二度とその場所にはと
そこで行者たちがそこら辺で命の儚さをじりじりと観察する
世界では何やっても結局は止まるところはここではないかと
それで遺体捨て場だったらもっと感動がすごいんですよ
あっちこっち遺体捨てて鎖かけていて
ですから このお墓に行って墓場に行って修行するということは
経典にあることはあるんだけど
現代社会ではもう全くも不可能ですよ
葬儀やっているところでもね
ものすごい豪華にゴージャスに作ってるでしょうね
そこでパーティーやりますからね
死者を弔うというところでしょうかね
よく食って帰ろうかな
どちらの気分かはわかりませんだけど
結局は今悲しみを演じる世界になっているんですね
決まり決まり 決まり 行々だけで
だから親戚はこの服で
こんな形で 写真はこうやって持っていってとかね
で なんとか板で何か書くん
そこをこうやって持っていったりとかね
撮り方 こういう撮り方やと
こういう風にも左手上か右
いろいろありますから
だから死んだ人 亡くなって悲しいというもうほとんどもう消えてるんです
お祭りやるんだからね
そういうふうに社会は変わりましたし
どんどんどんどん俗世間に欲に溺れる世間にも
いくらなんでももう変わっちゃうんですよ
そういうことで 経典にも
いわゆる仏教の伝統の中でもいくつかの行があったんですけど
また今現代 それもできなくなっているし
その代わりにお坊さんたちは新しい行を作りますよ
一応 テーラワーダ世界ではもう別に日本の仏教よりは伝統は古いんだけど
もうやること全部一番最先端に新しいことをやってるんです
古い行が消えちゃうでしょうね
効き目がなくなっちゃうでしょうね
それで新しい行を作るんです
現代人に通じる 通じるようにと
例えばもうみんなもう金儲かることだけに必死で苦しんでるし
瞑想するような時間が暇がないんだよというと
ものすごく大騒ぎして大きさに宣伝して
もう大大会みたいな法事を設定する
いろんな人に頼んで もういろんな業者に頼んで協力してくださいとかね
これあんまり大きいイベントだから
一応テレビ放送もするし
それでみんな一斉に組んですごいマスでやりますよで
みんなまとめて じゃあみんなで明治神宮にしましょうと
だからもうそれでどうしようもないんですね
みんな気分よく もうすごいみんなで 10万人ぐらい一斉にもう唱えるともう並の力じゃないんですよ
ある時は 8月 スリランカテレビでちょこちょこと見ていて
この あの このいろんな不可思議な力があるということで
もういろいろ それは本当かなと
科学的にどう説明すればいいかとかいうディスカッションになったんですね
ある坊主なんですけど
そいつは全部否定しよう
否定しようと思っちゃうんですね
で 年取って出家した人で
何かコネがあってよくテレビに出るんです
で ヨーロッパのもう科学思考で
まあそれ否定しようとするんですよ
しかし このテレビから出てきたアナウンサーというか
番組をやってる若者若い男性でしたけど
その人が中立的な立場でもディスカッションに持っていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも その人にはもうどうしてもこのお坊さんが言うことに賛成できないんですね
で 彼がいろいろ例を出してくれるんですよ
1つ出したのは アナラダプラの菩提樹のあるところで
自分が主催というか テレビ放送したんだから
そちらに私が行きましたよと
そこでなんとかの名前の坊さんが来て座って
では始めましょうと で
みんなでじゃあまずサードゥーって言ってくださいって言った途端
もう10万人 大体 20万人ぐらい集まりますからね
人があの巨大な土地の中で一斉にサードゥーと言ったところで
あの雰囲気が全部変わりましたよと
もうそれからそちらにやっての全く別世界だよと
もうみんなの心グッと変わって
それでずっと静かな すごい清らかな波動で終わりまで
あれどういうことでしょうかと
あれぐらい人っていうのはね
何の命令もなく 何の警察もなく
あれほど大人しくして抑えておいて管理できるっていうことはね
どう説明しますかとか
ただの一人のお坊さんでしょうと
マイクロフォンの前に座っているのと
その人も一般人の方を向いて座っているわけじゃないんです
菩提樹の方 坂沢の方を見ているんだから
だからまあ そこで現代的なバージョンで
そのお坊さんがやっぱり現代的な行を作ってるんですよ
現代的な行を考えて主催してやってるんです
だから別に行が目的じゃないんです
そのお坊さんに聞いたって
なんであんたこんなへんてこりんなことやるのかって
こんなことやらなきゃみんな修行しないでしょうという答え
何のことなく出てくるんです
みんな戒律守ったり修行したりしないでしょうにと
だからぴったし理性で新しい行が始まりますから
我々いくら伝統を保持する保守派だと言っても
全く実際はもうどこに保守派とわからないぐらい
もういろんな新しいこと
考えてやったりする だから行っていうのはもうそんなもんですよ
正しい行だったらすぐ変わるはずなんです
効き目がなくなったらもう変えなくちゃいけないということになるんです
だから仏教では行がないっていうことにするしかないんですね
だって変えますからね
行は変えてはいけませんだから
もう大体結構まあ五年ごとにかなり変わりますよ
向こうの仏教のしきたりやら
もうやることとかね で
あんまり効き目がないものはすぐそのまま消えてしまうし
効き目がある行だったらもう続けていっちゃうし
だからずっともう十年
二十年 三十年は続きません
効き目がなくなっちゃうと
また新しいものを考えて
誰かが考えてやるんです
だからこのなぜかというと
まあブッダの教えははっきり曖昧なく教えがしっかりしていますから
要は覚ることであって
要は心清らかなところにあって
要は人格向上することにあって
でもこのだらしない連中がやってるんだから
もうくれませんだから
じゃあ何とかしようではないかと
何とか工夫しようという感じで工夫するんです
だから しきたり 行は独り立ちはしない
教えが下にあるんだから
行は崩れてしまうんです
だから人間やっていることだから
どうしても規則ができちゃうし
だから規則できてくると何となく行っぽく見えるんです
だからそれは行というよりは規則ですね
何か規則決める 人間が決めた規則だから
まあいらん時はもうそれは変えちゃえばいいんです
宗教的な行っていうのはそう変えることはできませんだからね
では試しにね 真言密教でやってる護摩供養をやめてくださいと
やめられますかと それやめちゃうと何もなくなっちゃうんです
お寺として何すればいいかと
だって教えがないでしょ
理論がないでしょ 護摩供養で何か人間人格向上に何かある？何もないでしょうに
もし護摩供養をやることで人格向上に影響を与える何かあったならば
お坊さん その護摩やめたらどうでしょうか？と言っちゃうと
お坊さんがはい わかりました
それやめて その代わりにこういうことをしますよと別なことを提案できるはずなんです
それはできない その代わり日本的大体新しいものを考えるのは若者ですけど
日本の若いお坊さんたちでも新しいものを考えたりしますよ
しかし 残念なことに 本人が何か新しいことをしたいという気持ちはあるんですけど
教えがないんだから支えてくれる理論がないんだから
何やるかというと まあ現代若者と同じくギターを持って歌うとかね
[笑い]それで歌うことになっちゃうと
また音楽の世界に入り込んじゃって
また儀式行になるんであって
本人が歌でも通じて ロック音楽でも通じてブッダのメッセージをという目的でしたけど
いうメッセージも持ってないし
結局はいかにしっかり音楽を歌う歌うかということになってしまうんです
それで若者は来るんですけど
あまりお金もかからず演奏できる
練習できるんだからそれをするだけであって
その若者狙いは自分がそれで成仏したではないかということになっちゃうんですから
結局は人格向上という目的からそれてしまいますよ
だから別に音楽をやって悪くないんですよ
それで 歌でどんなメッセージを伝えるかという
それを持ってないと お寺で歌を歌ったんだからといってね
別にロックコンサートやって別に悪くないんです
どこかのお寺でピアノコンサートとかね
プロの人やってますけど
あれも何の意味もない
単なる西洋人の音楽をやるだけで
お寺で集めておばさんたちが音楽を聴いていて
ピアノリサイタルを聴いていて
ただ単にお寺に来ただけの結果で終わっちゃうんです
お寺に来たのは 有名な人のピアノリサイタルを聴きたいんだからなんです
そこで半年前からチケット買わなくてもよろしいし
だからそういうふうな現代儀式というか
現代行っていうのは 日本のお寺でもやっぱりいろいろ考えてやってはいるんですよ
だから私はこの新しいことを考え出したというところまではもう賛成する
必ずしも伝統的な儀式でなくてもよろしいんじゃないかというところはいいんだけど
やっぱり伝統的な儀式にも中身がないし
新しくその代わりに作るものにも中身がなくなってしまうんです
だからちゃんと何か教えが必要ですよ
理論的なというか ちゃんとした人格を
こういうものであるという真理は必要なんです
真理がなくなっちゃうと
もう無意味無駄ということになっちゃうんですね
そこで真理といえば 別に行がなくても成り立ちます
真理は真理ですから 別に
事実ですから だから仏教はそこら辺で中世的な立場をとっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで もう何もしきたりもする余裕もなくて
時間もない人でも 教えを学んで理解して
自分の体で経験してみるということはもうすごく可能ですよ
それで お釈迦様こういうところでいうのは
一般的にはお釈迦様の在家の弟子たち
在家信者さんが普通に商売して普通に生活している人々も預流果に悟っているし
そちらと比較すると あの厳しい行をやっている愚か者のことは何の価値もありませんと
三足？ 二足三文  二足三文やと
だからもうなんで価値ゼロと言わないのかというと
すごい大変ご苦労様でしたから
その人々も だからゼロとは言わないんですね
その代わりにゼロに等しいと言うんです
ゼロとは言わない このエピソード長いんですね
注釈書では 原本では 何か省略したところないんですかね
それでこの これ ちょっと何とか
これストーリーはちょこっと空口で面白いストーリーなんですけど
まあまあ 何かっつって言いたいんですけどね
難しい カッサパブッダの時代でね
うーん カッサブッダというのはお釈迦様に前にいたブッダのことなんですね
いわゆる一年といえば
何年も経ってはいるみたいですけど
その時のお話で あるお坊さんがある信者さんの家で毎日食事をもらっていて
その村に突然阿羅漢が来て
阿羅漢はあちこち旅するんですから
だいたい一箇所にはいないっていうかね
人に会う 会うことで人はヴィパッサナーもするし
説法もできるし ですから
何も執着もないし だから何も持たず
寺も持たず いろいろあちこち行ったり来たりする
だからこの村にも行きましたし
だから阿羅漢聖者っていうのはいたらすごい
ものすごい影響力 迫力がありますから
で 仏教の人々はすぐそれを感じ取っちゃうんですよ
三宝に帰依している人は
もうすぐ感じるんですね
これはやっぱり指導者やと
この人は自分の世界で本物の先輩であるとすぐ感じちゃうんです
それでこの在家の人が
客として来たお坊さん見たところで
いきなりもう喜んで一生懸命ご馳走してあげて
阿羅漢が旅をしているんだから
もう随分髪の毛も伸びちゃって
髭も伸びちゃって ボロボロですね
服もボロボロで 衣も だからすごい
すぐ自分がもう服をね
インドでは服は高価ですからね
もう服を 布を持ってきて
もうこんな これはもう着られませんだからね
ボロボロだから衣を作りましょうと言って
もうそこ持っていって
衣を色を染めなくちゃいけないんだから
染めて衣にしなさいと
それを行者に頼んで 行者に頼んで
それでまたあの信者さんがお金払って
床屋さんに もうあんた来て
このお坊さんにちゃんと髪の毛と髭を剃ってあげてくださいと
整理してあげてくださいと
至極面倒を見ているんですね
で 毎日行っているお坊さんがとってもないし
修行もしていないし これはすごく嫉妬するんですね
あの家族の面倒は私が毎日のように見ていると
自分に仏教の法事やら何でも毎日やっている人のことはほとんどあまり気にしない
ごく普通 一般的な扱いで
それにしたら 誰の誰かもわからないこの客のお坊さんに対しては
なんだこの様と このすごいもう丁寧で
もうもう腕を振るってやっているんではないかと
それでこの 次の日もあのお坊さん二人で家に食事に来てくださいってところで
この人はもう嫉妬して朝起こさなかったんですね
お坊さんを起こす必要はないんですけど
阿羅漢だから寝ていたわけじゃないんですけど
本人がちょこっと指だけ指でちょこっとドアに叩いて
聞こえないぐらいの声でね
で そのまま出て行っちゃったんです
そしたら信者さんがあのお坊さん
客のお坊さんはああ 彼が寝ているでしょうねと
ドアは叩いたんですけどね
返事はなかったと でも信者さんがそれ何の事？あ
そうですか まあいいわ別に
ということで この人にご飯をあげて
また箸にすごい丁寧にもうご馳走すごい丁寧に入れておいて
これ持って行ってあげてくださいと
でも阿羅漢のお坊さんが
まあそれ知ってね これがとんでもないことになりましたと
で 阿羅漢に対して嫉妬を抱き
嫌悪 憎しみを抱くこと
すごい罪になるし 私がこちらにとるとこの野郎がね
もう地獄に落ちますよと
いうことで さっとそこから出て行ったんです
で この人は ご飯を何したか
これを忘れてたんですけど
あのご飯捨てましたね
で 持って行かないで捨てちゃって
お寺にもう彼が何するかっていうと
こんなご馳走を食べると
この人はね このお寺で定住するでしょうと
ということで ご飯も捨てて
ひどい目に遭わせてやるぞと
お寺に行ったら もうこのお坊さんがいないんですね
探しても探しても この罪でこの人はもう地獄に落ちちゃうんですよ
だから阿鼻地獄なんですけど
これはものすごい悪い罪だからね
これ重罪の人々落ちるところですけど
あの重罪の人は落ちる地獄は阿鼻地獄と呼ぶんですけど
なんか変ですよ この地獄は
ものすごい苦しみが多く
大きいし 重罪を起こす人々は確実に落ちるところでしょう
しかし 寿命は決まっているんです
一劫ですね 劫っていうのは一応宇宙の時間ですから
一劫ですよ そこで宇宙は破壊すると
時間 地獄ももう潰れてしまいます
そこでどこかで生まれ変わるんであって
もう地獄は終わるんです
そういうことだから まあ寿命ははっきり決まっています
他の地獄の場合は おそらくそれより寿命は短いかもしれませんし
他の地獄に来たら 罪が終わったら解放されます
阿鼻地獄の場合は 罪が終わったら解放じゃなくて
一旦落ちたら地獄の寿命全部完了しなくちゃいけないんです
だからといって永遠という意味じゃないんですよ
現代人から見れば永遠でしょうね
宇宙の時間一つですからね
あるいは太陽系一つの寿命だと思ったっても構いません
短く計算して こちらに落ちちゃったんですね
いて まあだからもう数年に言いますけど
阿鼻地獄に落ちたければ
宇宙の寿命が最後の時落ちた方が楽です
宇宙の最初の時期で落ちたら
もうかなり長い時間 いる羽目になります
で そこでまた人間界に
また人間の世界現れるんだから
人間界に生まれたんですけど
ブッダの時代で でも過去の罪の残りは持っているんです
一旦罪は一応償ってますけど
なんかこのほんのちょっと
また癖というか 残っていて持っていて
この人はどうしても服は着たくない
で 子供の赤ちゃんの時からも自分のうんこ食べちゃう
とにかく食べる そこで親が
まあ子供だから知らないんだからこんなことやってるんだよと思って行ったんですけど
これは治らないんですね
全然 で 大きくなっても服は着ません
全く服を着替えすることもできないし
ご飯は食べないし そうなってくると
家ではもう何かも変でしょうね
もう生活できんでしょうに
で どうもならんだから
もうあの このアージーヴァカという宗教に
そちらはまあいろいろなしきたり
習慣 いろんなものある組織なんです
統一していないんです
アージーヴァカという人々は
で 自分好きな行やればいいんです
それでまあ他の宗教に入っちゃうとそちらの行に入れ替えなくちゃいけないし
こいつはもう話も自分の生き方変えませんし
ですから 親が選んだのはアージーヴァカに出家させるしかないんだよと言って出家させるんですよ
子供頃ですよ それでこのアージーヴァカの出家っていうのは
穴を掘って穴にその人を入れて
出家する人をね 入れて
穴の上からこの儀式をやっている先輩の行者たちが髪の毛を抜くんです
で ここまで穴に植えておいて
ここで板で固定してもらって
上からは全部もう髪の毛全部抜くんです
1本1本 かなり厳しいんですけど
で それでもこの人は服なんかも着る気持ちも全くないし
それで大丈夫でしょうし
次にあの親も先々までではもう明日お布施しますよとみんなにということをね
言ったら まあこの人は
じゃああんたのためでしょうし
みんなやっているのはね
ですからみんなで食事に行きましょうと言ったところで
この人は私は行きませんと
行かないんです で みんな出て行ったら
これをもううんこ食べちゃうんです
全然行かない ったらあんたご飯食べないどうするのかと
え ご飯食べましたからと
大丈夫ですよと ただこれは
で 他の人々は仲間がね
これはもうずっと待ってて
全然もうご飯には行かない
托鉢には行かない 聞いたら
ご飯もう食べましたから
これではね まあご飯食べなかったら死んじゃうでしょうね
死んでるわけでもないし
もうこれなんかおかしいと
といっても内緒で何やってるのかと
一人のアージーヴァカさんが調べたんですね
ただ みんな出て行ったところで
この人は便所はもう徹底的にきれいにするんですね
こちら書いてるのは両手で取ってパクパクと食べていたんだと
それがバレたら アージーヴァカさんにしても
いくら変な行をやってる組織なんですけど
これはいくらなんでも
これは認めるわけにはいきませんと
もし仏弟子たちにバレたら
なるんですかと 我々の組織はと
仏教弟子たちとはそんなにいい関係あったんだからね
ジャイナ教もアージーバ組織もジャティラ組織も
大体仏教弟子たちは結構関係は良かったんですね
だから いくらなんでも社会で人気のある仏教弟子たちの関係は壊したくないんですよ
これだったら大変なことになりますって追い出すんですよ
追い出したら この人はもうどうしようもなく
一人で別なところで生活
そこでそういうすごい厳しい行者が一人で生活してるんだと思って
そちらにまた信者さんがお布施を持っていく
もう私はご飯食べませんよと
どうやって生活するの？私はもう自然のエネルギーで生きてますよと言って
人々が来ると何か外へ待って
足を上げて手を上げて待ってるみたいですね
そうすると すごい行者だとみんなに褒められるようになりましたと
ご飯も食べないと しかし
体は元気やと なんでご飯食べないの？そんな
それはもう何か中国の気功系にもそういう話ありますけどね
宇宙のエネルギーで生きているとかね
で それでも人々はやっぱりそんな阿羅漢に仕留めちゃっていうことで
結構食べ物は持っていく
この人食べません だからお願いしたら
我々にはもう何とか得を済ませてくださいと言うと
葉っぱで 草の葉っぱでちょこっと舐めてみる
はい ごちそうさまでしたと
それも草という種類の葉っぱを取って
何も付けませんしね それで舐めて
はい どうぞ ごちそうさま
そういうことで みんな信者さんが自分持ってたご飯食べて出ていきますから
みんなあっちこっちもうもうもう何て言いますか
用を足していくんだからね
これはもう後で全部食べよう
そこでお釈迦様はその人のところに行くんですね
いくらなんでも それでお釈迦様がやっぱりこの人がかつて修行していたんだからね
嫉妬したんだからと言って
そのお坊さんが戒律破ったわけでもないし
ちゃんと地味にお坊さんだから徳はあるんですよ
でも罪を犯したんだからね
戒律は破ってないんだけど
罪を犯しちゃったんですね
で それ地獄のうちだって
その業で苦労しているんですね
お釈迦様が もう業の残りももうそろそろ赤ちゃんの時からもう大人になるまで
ずっともう厳しい生活をしていたんだから
もう業の力がもうそろそろ消えたでしょうというところで
それはちゃんと計算してそちらに行くことにしたんですね
で 行くことにしたら やっぱり
神々はね お釈迦様何しようと
あんなところに行くとこじゃないんだと
あの人いるところはものすごく汚いんだからね
お釈迦様いるところにも神々も一応行くんだから
これ大変なことやと言って
お釈迦様行くことに決めた途端
ものすごく雨を降らせて降らせて
あの場所はものすごく綺麗にしちゃったんだと
で この人はそれ知らないんだよ
お釈迦様はそれから後から行くんですね
お釈迦様がいらっしゃる時は
やっぱり場所はもう雨に全部もう大雨で流されてなんかされてものすごい綺麗になっているんです
そこら辺に行って お釈迦様は何のことなくこの人にもう何か変な名前で呼んだんですよ
ジャンブカっていう名前なんですけど
本人の名前かどうかはわかりませんだけど
なんとかすごい あの なんか貶すような名前なんですね
一応名前かもしれませんだけどね
大きい声で名前を呼ぶ
ジャンブカ ただ この人は自分がすごい修行者だと思ってるんだからね
敬語なしにもう何してて言うんですか
え？呼称 それに腹が立ったんです
ブッダはやっぱり誰にしたっても呼び捨てなんですよ
呼び捨てしない場合は
まあタイトルで呼びます
サイキの人よとかね ここよとかね
それ使わない場合は名前だけで
だから まあそれは王様たちにも名前だけで呼び捨てでね
まあ呼んでいたし だからまあこんな人に呼び捨てというのは当たり前でしょうし
で 怒ってなんだよと見たら
もうお釈迦様ってことを見て
まあそれで大沙門は知っているけど
大沙門 あんた何よと 大沙門
ああ それはね 私は一晩こちらで泊まらせてくださいと
本人にしてみれば これはもう絶対もうダメだから
いくら大沙門であろうとも
もう自分は一人で生活しているし
追い出されているし もう一人そこで一晩でも泊まっちゃうとバレちゃうし
自分の生き方は 怒ってこちらもうあんたにはもう住むとこはないんだよと
帰ってちょうだいと 場所がないんだよと
それでお釈迦様が言うのは
ジャンブカ そんなこと言わないでくださいと
一晩泊まらせてくださいと
我々みんな出家でしょ
出家は出家の心配するんだよと
宗教と関係ないよと お釈迦様は
我々みんな出家でしょ
出家はお互いに心配するもんでしょうと
それで人間は人間同士心配する
動物は動物同士でお互いに心配する
だから出家は出家同士でお互いに心配する
だから君一晩を泊まらせてくれよとお釈迦様めげないんです
[ドアが閉まる音]そこを言ったら
この人はお釈迦様にあなたも出家でしょうかと
そうだよと ただ あなたの出家道具は何やと
いわゆるジャティラさん
アージーカさんたちがいろいろもういろんな道具を持ってるんですね
水瓶とかいろんなもの
杖とかね いろんな道具も一つ持ってないでしょうと
で 座るものも持っていくんですよ
全部背負って それからみんなこの何かこのお数珠みたいなね
ヤンニスったって あの
いろんなもの唱える時はもう数えるためにすごいデッカいお数珠を持ったりとかね
で そういういろんな道具持ってます
一つもないでしょう あんたにはと
ブッダにそれないんだから
何も 杖もないし 水瓶も持ってないし
お数珠も持ってないし
他の儀式儀礼に必要な神宮御寺にあるようなね
いろんなものはもう何もないんですね
何もないでしょうと それでお釈迦様
はい そういうものは全部ありますよ
でもそんなものを一つ一つ持っていくのはね
面倒くさい だからあっちこっち置いてあるんだよと
それで怒って この人は
だったらあんたその道具全部揃ってあっちこっち来てたらどうでしょうかと
お釈迦様が まあそういえば
まあまあそれもいいかもしれませんだけど
そんな怒らないでくださいと
私はただちょっと一晩泊まるところくださいと言ってるだけでしょうと
でもあげてくれないんですね
それでお釈迦様はあっちこっち見て
こっちはなんかちょこっと崖の下で道具詰めてるところ
あちら誰もいないでしょうと
私はあちら泊まったらどうでしょうかと
見えないんです まずあちら誰か住んでますかと
そちらは誰も使ってませんよと言ったんです
それでもうダメだった
あちら誰か住んでますかと
誰も住んでませんよと
お釈迦さんにカンが起こっているのに
だったらそれ私にくださいと
もうあげませんよということは言えませんね
勝手にしろよと 勝手にしろよと
でお釈迦様は何のことなくそちらに勝手に行って
まあ座ったんですね そうやってまあ夜になってくると
やっぱりもういろいろもう神々が
夜は必ずお釈迦様一人でいると
もう来るんです その場合は何の遠慮もなく
堂々と自分たちの姿で来るんです
人間がいるところではそういうふうには来ないんです
そのチャンスはだいたいお釈迦様一人になるチャンスというのは
だいたい神々みんなもう待ってるんです
そこであらゆる神々が挨拶に来る
そこで四天王が来て ４
人だからね なんかすごいもう光で
この人に光がサッと来るのを見て
であんたはすぐ横へ出て行ったら
あんたのとこなんか光が四つ落ちたような感じがします
あれ何です？あれ四天王が来ましたよと
あ そう あんた四天王より偉いんですかねと言ってまた帰って
またなんかすごい光が
またものすごい光が来て
それが終わったらまたあれ何ですかと
あれまあ大食仙が神の王様で来て挨拶に来ます
挨拶に来た ではあんたはそれより偉い？うん
偉いんでしょと お釈迦様
私は彼より偉いんだよ
それだけじゃなくて あ
あの人はね 私のあの看病までしてくれるんだよと
病気になったら なんかお釈迦様の何かお世話役やってるの
あの人はね まあ病気になったらよく面倒見てくれたりするしね
まあだから私の家来みたいなもんですと言うんですよ
お釈迦様は そこで最後にこのブラフマ神様が梵天から来るんですね
ブラフマ神様が来たら
もう四方八方 もうすごい光
白い特別な光を出しながら降りたんです
降りて挨拶をして まあバンで出て行ったところで
あれは何なのかと ものすごいんだと
力 あれはマハブラフマ
大梵天ですよと ったらこの人にはもう信じられない
普通は大梵天っていうのはもう人間
人類みんな創造した神様だと思ってるでしょう 「
あんたあの人よりも偉いんだよ
偉いに決まってるでしょう」と
言ったらもうそこでもうそれ以上は我慢できなくて
やっぱり人類みんなマハーブラフマーに「ナモ・ブラフマー
ナモ・ブラフマー」ずっと言ってるところで
神様へね これもう沙門のところに来て挨拶しに来たんだよということで
ブッダの話を まあ聞かなくちゃということになったんですね
そこで 「私は今年間修行してますよ」と 「
私のところにはこんなもう誰も教わりに来たわけじゃないんだよ」と
お釈迦様ね 「あんたはもう詐欺や」と
はっきり言うんです 「
あんたは偽善者や」と 「
あんたみんな騙してるんだよ」と 「
それで私も騙されているんだけど
私は騙されませんよ」と
で 言って 「この人やること
あんたこういうこういう人ではないか」と
言って 「あんたはね こうなっているのはこういうこういうことである」と
言って全部言っちゃったんですね
あんた昔もこういうことをやって
それからこういう風になっている
それで生まれてきて 今こんな生活していて
もうずっと教えないってことで黙ってるんだと
で 彼がやっぱり説法を聞くんですよ
を聞いたところで 過去生を全部言われたところで
ものすごくもう思い出してね
恥ずかしくなって そのまま初めて生まれてから年ですよ
年は 初めて恥ということを知って
お釈迦様のところにしゃがみ込んだんですね
もう裸でいたんだから
お釈迦様がこの それで
あの まああの 沐浴したりするときは
腰巻を一つ巻いて沐浴して
それはもうまた干して別室に置いておくんです
それやりましたから それをあげたんで 「
これを着なさいよ」と
それが彼が腰に巻いて
巻いてお釈迦様のところにしゃがみ込んで
やっぱり説法を聞いて
悟るんですよ あれほどもう汚い生活をやっていた人なんですけど
悟り開いたら まあお釈迦様に出家したいんだと
そしたら「まあいいよ」と
それで出家認める でもとにかくお釈迦様から直々出家してもらったっていうことだから
普通は出家儀式がありますよ
会議でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
サンガの で お釈迦様だけは何の会議もなく
一言で出家っていうね 「
はい 結構です」と 「いいですよ」って言ったら
それで出家なんです 「
認めます」と その「認めます」という言葉っていうのは
なかなかみんなに得られることはできないんです
その一言葉は だからもう微妙にすごい立場がいいんですよ
サンガで出家認めたわけじゃないんだけど
サンガの一員ですからね
お釈迦様のもう特別特権で
だから他のお坊さんたちに何一つも言うことはできない
だからお釈迦様出家を認める人々はみんな阿羅漢なんです
阿羅漢になった瞬間で
その以外は認めません
だから 在家の人でも説法を聞いて
その場で阿羅漢になったら
それから出家するしかないんですよ
そこで その瞬間でお釈迦様はもう出家認めて出ていくんです
だから釈尊に直々出家を認めた人々には
もうもうそこその時点でもう特権は特権になっているんです
阿羅漢であることは言わなくても阿羅漢ですね
だからまあサンガで集めて
あなたは正しく出家していないんですよと
あなたの師匠は誰ですかと
いないでしょうと 法師はいないでしょう
あなたには とかね これはもう聞く権利は何もなくなっちゃうんです
年間あなたは誰の師匠のところでもう見習いやったんでしょうかとかね
何も肩書がないんです
何もできない 相手はブッダですからね
それ出家するんですよ
そこで次の朝 夜 これをできて終わって
次の朝またいっぱい信者さんがこの祭りの日があるんですよ
おそらく満月でしょうね
満月の祭りで信者さんが大勢来るんですよ
すごい行者のところだから
来たところでこの人は服を着ているし
ブッダもそちらにいるんでしょうし
みんななんかあれどうなってるんでしょうかと
あの沙門がこの人の弟子になったんでしょうかねと
だって我々のすごい人だからとかね
彼らの信者さんたちだからね
はぁ すごいことですね
我々の先生は あの大沙門も弟子にしているみたいですよとかね
いったっても 自分の先生
また服を着ているんだからね
形違いますよね あんな汚い状況でもないし
場所もすごい綺麗になってるし
もう上弦は着て出て行った場所だから
みんなあっちこちグーグーグー喋ってるところで
お釈迦様がこの人の顔を見たんです
こうやって 見たら その人がすぐそこで立ち上がって
私はお釈迦様の弟子になりましたと
そこでみんなに発表してお釈迦様に名をもたせて礼をするんです
で  それのエピソードについて
お釈迦様がこの偈を言ったと
愚か者はあんな風なやることやったって意味がないんだと
サンカーラダンマっていうのは
この場合は阿羅漢になることなんですよ
注釈書では夜かに覚ることでもサンカーラダンマだよと
真理を経験することこそが価値があるものであるというふうな説法をなさったそうですね
それで それからはもう彼があの赤裸々習慣
全部もう消えちゃったんです
で まとめる出家の阿羅漢として生活をしたんです
そこでこのエピソードは
なんで私は苦労しながら長い長いエピソードをね
一応省略して言ったのかというと
すごいこのもう嫌味あるんです
その中に ストーリーの中で
この人にはすごい信者さんがいて
もう大聖者大聖者だとものすごい世間大騒ぎしていたんです
当時のその辺の人々は
かなり人気あったみたいですよ
だってご飯食べないということをみんな知っているんだから
他何食べてるかって誰も知らない
それはものすごい内緒でやっているんです
そこは言ってるんです
あなた方はもう一生懸命行をやって人を拝んでるんですけど
本当はこのクソ食ってる人々をやっていることを言ってるんです
だからこういうこの行をやってる儀式をやってるところに大勢群がってる人々を極限に馬鹿にしているんです
いろんな新興宗教組織みたいな感じで
なんか変なことやってるところザーッといくでしょうね
昔 オウムの時でも ものかなり大人気でしたからね
仏教はこういう言葉で
もうもう何も残らないように綺麗さっぱりもうけなす
そこはもう裏で何のことなく親切に言ってるんです
何の立ち触りもないようにと
両手でパクパクとこそこそ隠れて
で 表になってくると大聖者だよと
その人なら一般人が一生懸命拝んでますよと
いうことで もうかなり厳しいんですよ
このストーリーのメッセージは
だから私の嫌みの言葉っていうのはそれほど結束はないんです
だから 教典とか仏典になってみると
並大抵じゃないんです
非難するときは うん 大体そんなもんですね
ですから 何時まで？まあ一応今日我々学ぶべきところは
知識的なね 現代的な学ぶべきところは
この儀式と道徳のこの微妙な関係ですね
儀式だけなら道徳とは全く関係なくなっちゃう
道徳は儀式なしには成り立つ
しかし 我々のだらしない性格は
儀式っぽいもので制御することもできないわけではないんです
それは儀式っぽいと言った方が儀式で性格は直せると言ってはいけません
そうすると邪教になっちゃうんです
儀式では性格は直りません
行では しかし 行っぽいもので人格を制御することはできます
そういうわけで 仏教でも行っぽいものはあります
それはいつでも変えてもよろしいんです
行にはあまり意味がないんです
ですから 例えば花祭りを盛大にやりましょうと思っても
それは構いません 花祭りやることによって
ブッダのメッセージにブッダに触れてもらおうとかね
そこで精神のいくらかになってくる何か行であるならばね
じゃあ瞑想してみるとかね
お釈迦様の話とかを聞いてもらおうとかね
善巧意でもね ブッダが誕生した日だからね
それで最大にお祭りして善巧意しましょうというふうに
道徳的な人格的なものならもう祭りは OK なんです
しかし 花祭りで花だなんとか作って
そこで甘茶かけて それでご飯食べて帰るならば
これはただの儀式で 精神的にはもうあまり意味がなくなってしまうんですね
だから新しいお祭り考えて作ったってもいいんだけど
やっぱり精神的に何か訴えるものがなければ意味がないんです
というわけで 仏教の世界ではいくら何でもいくらでも新しいお祭り考えることは可能です
新しい儀式はいくら作ることでも可能ですし
いくらでも取り消しも可能です
儀式には執着しない 儀式はあくまでも道具にしておいて
道具は利かなくなっちゃうと捨てるものです
だから道具としては OK なんです
なぜ道具っていうのは道具で別なことするんだから
道具を拝むんじゃないんです
包丁で料理をするんであって
包丁を拝むんじゃない
ないんです だから包丁はもう切れなくなっちゃうと捨てればいいんです
そこで包丁ではみじん切りできないんだったら
今機械もありますからね
じゃあ包丁はやめて機械でやろうと
でもよろしいんです 道具ですから
だから道具は何でもいいんです
機能してくれるならば
卵のスライスする道具ありますね
だからこれ卵スライスする
これはとても尊いものだという意味がないんですよ
これは役に立ちますよと
見事に均等にスライスしてくれるんですよ
そこでこのスライスするあれがもうちゃんと金属のあれで切っちゃいますから
あれはちょっと緩めてしまって
卵がぺちゃっと潰れるんだったら
もう捨てるしかないでしょうね
スライスしてくれませんだから
それで卵潰れちゃいます
それだったら捨てましょうと
そんなことで包丁でやってもいいんですけど
包丁で卵を均等にスライスすることはできる人もいて
できない人もいる じゃあ包丁をやめましょうと
じゃないと それでも卵を切る機械を使いましょうと
これ使ってうまく一回
二回行ったんですけど
四回目  100円ショップで買ったんだから
やっぱり三回目はもううまくいかない
卵潰れちゃいますよと
それだったら捨てるしかないんです
そういうことで 儀式 儀礼
行っていうのは道具として見た方がいくらか理解しやすい
という道具は道具で尊いわけじゃないんです
やってくる仕事によって
仕事もいくらか価値があるんであって
仕事の方が大事なんです
だから見事に仕事をしてくれる道具はずっと残るんです
ということになります
話は終わりです というわけであらゆる儀式
儀礼がなくても ちゃんと心を清らかにすること
瞑想会に来なくても 仕事をしながら怒らないで
落ち着いて どんどん立派な人間になるために頑張ることでもものすごい尊いなんですよ
普通に会社に行って 仕事をして
そちら辺でいるあらゆる人間関係をよく観察して
慈しみで怒らず 興奮しないで
落ち込むこともしないで
ちゃんと真面目に仕事をしながら自分の人格を向上する
こんなもういろんな変な人々の環境の中で
自分がどのように自分の人格を育てていくのかと
それで立派になれば それも正真正銘のものすごい立派なことであって
ですから 仏教徒になるというためには何もシンボルないでしょ？十字架ぶら下がっていたりとかね
ないんです 作ってもそれはただのおしゃれだけ
こちらでも あの 何でしたか
あれは 仏教のペンダント
ペンダント言わない 何でしたっけ
バッジとかね あれはおしゃれでいいんです
それ着けたんだからって特別に人格向上するっていうことはないんです
[笑い]